we have more news this morning actually
a bizarre twist in a missing person's
case that was not quite what it seemed
earlier this week Texas officials said
that a 25 year old named Rudy farias was
found alive this after allegedly
Vanishing when he was a teenager back in
2015. now police say all of it was a
hoax Janet shamlin has the story for us
from Houston
a Houston teen reported missing by his
mom eight years ago was actually at his
home Houston Police say oh that time it
was discovered that Rudy returned home
the following day on March 8th 2015.
Janie Santana earlier this week reported
her son Rudy farias now 25
had been found outside a church
disoriented but alive
news of his alleged return made national
headlines
after eight long years Rudy has been
located safe the Texas Center for the
missing wrote on Twitter but none of it
was true according to police in fact
both Janie Rudy's mother and Rudy
himself gave fictitious names while
interacting with various Patrol officers
the story of
and one of his aunts says she was duped
into searching for him she had me out
there in California thinking that they
had found somebody that looked like Rudy
now Newsweek is reporting Janie Santana
benefited from a GoFundMe account set up
after she reported Furious missing
police say the investigation is ongoing
but the D.A will not file charges for
the fictitious report at this time a
decision baffling relatives why in the
freaking world that they let her go
authorities say Ferry slept with his mom
after police questioning for CBS
mornings I'm Janet shamlian in Houston